the jurogan experience i remember
watching
mr jones on uh mtv
and uh i i loved that [ __ ] video man
and i loved that you dancing in that
was it like a living room or something
like that yeah yeah i'm like i want to
be that
free like you seemed so loose you were
so
in the moment i remember thinking that i
was remember talking to a friend of mine
that let uh that night after a
show i was at a bar i was like you ever
seen that mr jones video
like when that dude's dancing i go i
want to like figure out how to get there
[ __ ] i want to be that free you know
it's a weird thing i used to i'm going
to take this off for now okay
i used to be for me you know
life is often very awkward and
uncomfortable
but not on stage you know like on stage
i always felt like well this is the one
place on
everything i do is fine right so when i
started you know making videos
at first it was just like this is
apps this is easy because all i got to
do is do the stuff
i'm going to do you know and and there's
nothing wrong i can do i can just be as
free as i want
and that lasted about a year and a half
maybe two years
something out like getting really famous
out of nowhere and then
you know all the kind of backlash that
comes with it i noticed a couple years
later i was a lot more
self-conscious i'm still on stage i
never think about anything
when i'm playing it nothing bothers me
but in front of cameras
i got really self-conscious in front of
cameras after
sometime in the middle of our second
record i just noticed that i started to
suck on not suck on video but
definitely not like that mr jones video
you just became
aware that so many people were watching
and criticizing you or like what was it
i think it was that you know because at
first i just uh
well didn't care and i just thought that
there's nowhere in the world i'm more
comfortable than here so i'm fine
and then i think on our second album
when we got a lot of backlash and you
get a little too big and everybody you
get you annoy the [ __ ] out of people
yeah you know especially because in a
band because
you get a really successful song they're
going to play it on the radio every five
minutes after a while it's like
god who wouldn't get sick of it you know
yeah and then you get some backlash
after that people say some terrible
things
and then and then i started thinking
about like what do i look like on film
then i got really self-conscious
you know what's does this look my does
this song make my ass look big
you know and uh i noticed that i got
kind of crappy
in just in front of cameras not the rest
of the time and not like cameras when
i'm on stage at a concert like you play
a big festival there's lots of cameras
and none bothering me there
it's just kind of sometimes on tv and in
in
filming i got kind of self-conscious and
i had never been that way
the press stuff like that kind of stuff
i think so i mean i don't really know
what caused it exactly
i would the only reason i would say i
think you're right about that is that
is that it happened then you know and
that was the first time i'd experienced
that because you know
no one said anything bad about you when
they don't know you exist for one and
then
on our first record we couldn't buy a
bad review you know and
but by our second record it was we
weren't even getting it was like
forget him he's [ __ ] this chick so i
don't have to
forget his music you know and then like
he got fat whatever it would be
you start you know when you're
nationwide but a national publication
calls you fat
you know it's like [ __ ] i remember
getting a review in like in england once
and somebody
called me ponzi is a fishmonger's cat
which i suppose fishmonger's cats cat's
eating auntie like is that like chubby
bunny i thought it i thought it meant
chubby i assume
i guess i don't know it just sounded bad
being compared to a fishmonger's cat
the fact that fishmonger is involved at
all as a word when they're talking about
your concert
seems like a bad sign you know yeah
there's a thing that happens right like
when people discover you
and they find out about you and you
haven't gotten big yet
like especially for bands i think where
they
they they love the fact that they're the
first to tell their friends
you gotta listen to this band gotta
listen this album this is awesome
but then when you get really big and
other people like it
and too many people like it then like oh
man they were good in the beginning
well i think i think you're i mean i
think that music unlike
almost everything else it becomes our
personal cool you know i mean we
literally wear it on our shirts
right you know and and it defines who we
are we talk about this
genre or that genre as being our gang
almost
and when when you're discovering stuff
yeah it's really cool
and then when you have to share it with
that guy at the water cooler who likes
the [ __ ] worst music you know that
guy who's been coming in for years and
he's just listening to utter [ __ ] yeah
and now he loves your band too and
you're like i don't want to share this
with captain [ __ ] over there you know
and uh i've never understood that
because why can't people with terrible
taste also like great things
like great things are great no matter
what like everybody loves the godfather
right yeah yeah it's like whoever says
that that movie sucks
nobody but people who like terrible
movies still like the godfather
you know well i think it's less because
they now like it as that you're now as
opposed you were in a club without them
right and now you're in a club with them
and that just sucks because you didn't
have to be in a club with them before
right it's human nature i mean i get it
i i didn't like it when it landed on me
but uh yeah i mean i get it well and it
happened to you
pre-social media yeah you were
you guys were just getting reviewed by
experts
you weren't get [ __ ] on by the general
public yet
no i mean but that was kind of that was
a good thing for one but
i was really into so right well it's for
me
it had happened when i was kind of
already into social media because
i remember moving down to la after our
first album
and that year while i was writing the
second record discovering that aol
had these uh like message boards so this
is 95
say and i realized that aol had these
forums and message boards for all the
bands and it suddenly occurred to me
well i could just go on there
and talk to people because when i read
it they were worried about were we ever
going to make a second record
where were we going to [ __ ] did we exist
anymore like what
all the questions that you wonder about
your band between records and it
suddenly occurred to me well i could
i have the answers to all those
questions you know i could just go on
there and it took me a little while to
convince the people on there that i was
me
but uh understandably of course
but eventually i did and then we sort of
started this
kind of community there uh you know way
before
other social media but it occurred to me
because the rest of the time you
you can't get to your fans except
through or you couldn't then
except through the radio the dj's and
the press
so like you don't really get to give
anybody your own words they got to be
filtered through everybody else
right but that aol thing was a chance to
just like well like what twitter and
everything is now
but it occurred to me back then it was
really cool
and when people started then i got into
arguments with our own fans i've always
done that it's just like what kind of
arguments
well you know like i i don't think i'm
who they think i
am who do you think they think you are
um a classic rock guy driving around in
a pickup truck
like going to drive-in movie theaters
because that's this americana
dream vision of like we all sit around
you know
going to drive-ins and living some dream
of a springsteen song that springsteen
isn't even any part of you know
i would go on there and i'd be like have
you guys heard the first justin
timberlake album it's
amazing it's got like timbaland and the
neptunes doing all the songs
and i would try and make this thing tell
them like you should listen to this it's
brilliant music
and they just they couldn't grasp the
justin timberlake thing
because in their mind in sync was the
guy at the water cooler right you know
and so like i would get these huge
advice with them like you guys don't
know [ __ ] about music you're just like
you're in this little niche rigid you
know you like us and i i think that's
very smart and intelligent it shows a
lot of wisdom
but you're limited not getting all these
fights with them catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video and
audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download
episodes to save on data cost all for
free
spotify is absolutely free you don't
have to have a premium account to watch
new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience